rome depuis le début de cette vague de
violence urbaine la ville de marseille a
plutôt été épargné par les incidents
c'est suffisamment surprenant concernant
la deuxième ville de france pour qu'on
essaye de comprendre pourquoi
en fait les quartiers sensibles sont
totalement intégré à la ville ils ne
sont pas excentré et à marseille la
mixité sociale est une tradition
historique est une réalité quotidienne
le reportage sur place isabelle steiss
et benoît jourdain rouge hugo alors loin
de l'ambiance explosive des autres cités
françaises
les jeunes de marseille ne comprennent
pas la menace du couvre-feu dans leur
ville
la personne de dangereux de stockage
pour le cinéma comme ça pour marquer ça
veut dire quoi que ce soit à cause du
jeu passait le site de l'or au karcher
ou youtube pour moussa éducateurs né
dans la cité bellevue il ya 42 ans
maintenir le calme en ce moment demande
encore plus de dialogue avec les jeunes
c'est la force de ce travail de
proximité qui désamorce les tensions on
a le soleil et on a un peu tous points
et le travail qui se fait aussi bon a
abandonné tout ça il faut se dire il
faut arrêter de dire à marseille a rien
à marseille 1 à marseille a mais on a
autant des problèmes dans les mains nues
que dans les banlieues parisiennes et
lyonnaises ou strasbourgeoise cinq mille
personnes vivent dans la cité bellevue
qui n'a rien à envier aux banlieues
parisiennes
il ya bien quelques épaves de voitures
brûlées ces derniers jours des incidents
sont toutes habituel la mentalité
marseillais n'est pas la même et si
pendant le jeu plus familiale en il ya
beaucoup de chances de le rester des
plus anciens presque des familles
entières tous sens ça tient en trois
mois ce qui est en route
aux portes de marseille 225 mille
personnes vivent dans les quartiers nord
dans une douzaine de citer ici on ne
parle pas de banlieue le fait que ces
quartiers d'habitat collectif
soit au coeur de la ville contribue
évidemment à maintenir
voilà ce que ce soit dans la mesure où
justement le genre déplaçant mesure est
à deux pas du centre-ville
l'histoire de marseille se confond avec
l'histoire de ces quartiers populaires
et de ces classes populaires et c'est
vrai que quand on est demandé la jolie
on n'est pas parisien
quand on est de saint-antoine on est
marseillais je tiens de vraiment faire
ici au quartier non non ça va à
marseille aujourd'hui les mères de
famille n'ont pas peur de sortir dans
leur quartier